if you can have a conversation with  yourself around the values that you're  living by  it becomes much easier to then make  conscious choices that are in alignment  to those values so  I would actually encourage everybody to  have this conversation with their loved  ones or even just with themselves they  could write it down in a journal write  down their top values in life and how  their food choices can relate to those  values and then it becomes a lot easier  because you're taking away a lot of the  extra choices that you're having to make  or these social situations that you're  having to navigate because you are  consciously living in alignment with the  things that matter